hello everybody like to welcome you to
my home as you can see over there this
is my workshop and I am sitting on my
porch just hanging out we spent the last
week or so trying to get everything in
order there's still too much water to to
strip the basement and to take
everything out but the water has gone
down about a foot and a half I would say
there's probably about the same about
two feet my wife says and there's
probably about the same amount to still
to still go so now by now the water has
been in our basement for seven days and
so it's quite disgusting all around
today the police and the all the
firefighters all the security workers
have all left because they said they
found some diseases in the water and so
the water is now too dangerous to work
in so that's a lot of fun and and so
yeah so we are just trying to figure out
what to do trying to to get everything
done as much as possible and so yeah
we're still flooded and it's a very
strange mix of extremely disgusting and
extremely beautiful we're sitting there
in our house and we're looking out of
the window and we're surrounded by water
and so it's very it's very impressive
but scary as well so anyway so I just
wanted to give everybody a little bit of
news of what is happening I want to
thank everybody who has been writing me
giving me all this encouragement a lot
of people also have been supporting us
by sending money through PayPal I just
want to say thank you it is very
heartwarming I haven't been able to work
all week and I don't know also this week
if I'll be able to work so it's
comforting to know that we can kind of
focus on our stuff and try to get things
done in the order that it has to be done
once the water is out of the basement
then we have 48 hours to pump everything
out and to get everything stripped and
disinfected so that weird we don't put
our family and
if we decide to stay here we haven't
totally decided what we're going to do
with this house once the water is gone
we need to get see the extent of the
damage but uh but yeah those we're just
doing things one step at a time so once
again guys thank you for your support as
you know symbolism happens and yeah guys
see you soon